if you want a new twist on a favorite
dish spice it up with chili
my next recipe is super simple to make
but has wonderful depth and complexity
of flavors spicy beef salad
chilis if you use them confidently they
can really add a new dimension to the
style of cooking but the real trick is
finding that balance of flavors that
really suits you because that's the most
important part
so this is the most amazing sirloin you
can see it's got that wonderful marble
for me the secret behind this
is cooking it quickly season the steaks
generously
salt and pepper
push that seasoning in to the sirloin
take the sirloin out the fridge
literally 20 minutes before you want to
cook them so it gets up to room
temperature they cook more evenly but
more importantly you can actually season
right inside
the steak this little bit of fat down
here season that as well because that is
what we want to roast and get that
really nice and rendered olive oil in a
tablespoon
roll that round
as it starts to smoke in with the steaks
into the pan
and lay away
again
into the pan
and lay away if you don't hear that
noise the minute those steaks hit the
pan don't put them in so the secret now
is getting that color on the steak
turning it once and once only and
cooking it for two and a half minutes
each side what i want to do is to get
that bit of fat rendered so it adds a
lot more flavor just hold
the steak down like that
and that starts to melt the fat which
makes it so much more tender there
should be no white fat left anywhere
turn them over
really important to have that steak up
to room temperature before you start
cooking it so the inside is nice and
warm so we spend less time in the pan
and more time cooling down really
important
now two fingers touch
it goes in it says rare
i'm happy for them to be rare because by
the time i let them rest
they're going to go back to medium rare
it'll continue cooking
out onto a plate and let them rest
one to
just get my juices over
don't waste that really important
next the spicy dressing take the seeds
out of the chili to reduce the heat by
rubbing it in your hands and tapping
until the seeds fall out
cut it in half
and just chop it
in
garlic and chilli works brilliantly a
quick way of peeling it get your knife
and just
slam it down
pops out very very quickly in a little
touch of salt
rub
start going around in circles first
you'll see it puring
nice clear that off
now we've got the heat in there from the
chilli and that richness from the garlic
two teaspoons of palm sugar this is
where it starts to have that nice sweet
sour effect
fish sauce
fresh lime this is a simple fresh chili
dressing and it was something i fell in
love with in vietnam and cambodia
because it was just so easy
give that a little mix and dissolve the
sugar
quick taste
wow right vegetables
a great fuss-free way to get super thin
ribbons of carrot is to use a veg peeler
when they're that thin they take the
vinaigrette so much better and radishes
just slice them down at an angle
lovely to give another dimension to the
salad i'm gonna use a banana shallot
they are incredibly mellow
very sweet
across
just chop up
the shallot
and mix that through
want some sweetness in there now little
vine tomatoes slice them
in half smarter's in
shallot radish carrots and tomatoes
next peel and slice cucumber
chopped spring onions and shred baby gem
lettuce and then finally get some fresh
mint
it's young men so you don't need to take
all those stalks off all you do is hold
the bunch upside down and then take it
for a little trim
and just chop that once
through
look at that nice
minted
salad a couple of tablespoons of
dressing don't flood the salad with a
dressing you can always add but we can't
take it away now really mix that
dressing in there make sure all that
chili and garlic and palm sugar wraps
around that salad beautiful
onto the plate the steak's rested it's
now nice and medium rare that little bit
of fat we don't want to find that in the
salad just slice that off that serves
its purpose
it's kept that steak nice and moist
just slice going with the grain it's
almost like
slicing through butter and look inside
beautiful pink
you slice the beef too thinly then it
goes stone cold and more importantly all
the goodness runs out of it
nice thick slices
get the beef and start placing it around
the salad
take a little teaspoon
of your dressing the rest of your salad
sip that on top
and finish it off with some
toasted peanuts peanuts in
now those nuts
are really toasted nuts on
get another pan
and just
crush
once they've cooled down
just run them through with a knife
you can hear how crunchy they are
another
texture another taste the salad
and then from there sprinkle
and then finally
take that
just finish it with a little
tablespoon of that sauce
and there is one tasty very well
textured spicy beef salad
[Music]
cooking dishes in advance is a brilliant
way of taking the stress out of cooking
at home and many dishes just get better
and better with time
first up my amazing sticky pork ribs
one of the secrets to great cooking is
patience leaving dishes to marinade for
one or two days helps to develop the
flavor in your food and the end result
so much more delicious it's a method i
use in the restaurants all the time
first off get your roasting tray put the
tray on the gas
pork ribs 60 meat and 35 40 fat give
them a really good season salt
and pepper
nice thing about this cut they stay
incredibly moist when they're on the
bone and the longer you cook them the
more delicious they become and just push
all that seasoning in to the pork
olive oil in
make sure that tray is nice and hot
and i really want that nice sort of
caramelization taking place on the pork
that's the nice thing about starting it
on top of the stove use your roasting
tray get them colored and then the oven
putting the ribs straight in the oven
you don't get the color
it looks sort of boiled as opposed to a
nice caramelized rib
ginger
you can't beat fresh ginger with sticky
pork ribs
place it down nice and firmly and slice
the thinner you slice the ginger
the more fragrant the ribs
garlic
and it's really important before you add
anything
those ribs make sure you've got the
color from the ribs first don't rush it
turn them over that's what i want
that nice crispy color
as they sort of
braise in the oven all that color just
turns into the most amazing flavor
braising is just a chef's turn for
cooking something slowly in liquid
right ginger and garlic in
spread it around on all those ribs to
sort of roast the ginger and the garlic
chili flakes
chili flakes in next szechuan pepper
citrusy vibrant peppercorns incredible
in
next star anise that gives it a really
nice sort of aniseedy flavor almost like
you're roasting the ribs in fennel and
now we've got the heat
got the spice
i want to sweeten things up a little bit
some fresh honey
honey glazes the pork beautifully
counteracts against all that spice in
there
but look what's happening a color on the
ribs is extraordinary
it's like a really nice chili sweet
caramel now
soy sauce brings that little bit of sort
of saltiness to it
really generous with the soy sauce
japanese vinegar
two tablespoons of vinegar in
rice wine
it gives it that nice sort of um
tartness to the ribs
if you can't find rice wine our dry
sherry's a great substitute
300 mil
that takes out the heat of that sichuan
pepper those dry chili flakes make sure
they're all laid down like a nice tight
box of matches bring that up to the boil
cooking is all about learning to develop
your own likes and dislikes so always
keep tasting to make sure you're happy
with the combination of flavors
it's lacking a little touch of vinegar
what that sharpness
now think what's going on the tartness
the heat the caramel the colour on the
ribs is amazing i want a bit of a sort
of oniony flavor put some spring onions
in
whilst these ribs are in the oven the
spring onions will sort of puree they
give a sharpness
the final taste of that pork
in with my spring onions
and with my stock
400 ml of stock
this is just a
simple chicken stock
the stock just sits underneath the ribs
it absorbs into the rib and the top of
the rib glazes
underneath the rib that gets crispy and
rich and that's what makes the ribs nice
and moist really important into the oven
cook at 180 for 30 minutes
then turn the ribs over and cook for a
further 30 minutes
[Music]
now
wow they smell incredible
each side has got that really nice
crispy roasted edge becomes sticky and
chewy and sweet sour the fats
disappeared and the pork just melts in
your mouth i want to take them to the
next level gas back on now
shake the tray
and this is the sort of
the way that we finish them in the
restaurant
every minute
they glaze
in that tray they just get to taste
better and better
now look at them
i'm so happy with those
ribs done
absolutely delicious now but if you want
you can put them in the fridge and the
flavor will keep developing then just
reheat them when you want to serve
so
[Music]
each rib has a nice slice of ginger on
there
wow look at that
delicious sticky ribs
with an amazing marinade
[Music]
there's a wealth of classic fast food
dishes we know and love from hot dogs
and kebabs to tacos and burgers but the
great thing about making them at home is
you can throw away the rule book and get
creative
my next easy recipe is a miniature
version of an american favorite the
burger smoky pork sliders with barbecue
sauce
everyone loves a burger they're a true
fast food original and that's the
exciting thing about street food you can
take an old classic like that and
reinvent it into something really
exciting
when you think of a burger what you need
is a great sauce and unlike smoky
barbecue it goes hand in glove with a
great burger
start by finely chopping one onion and
three cloves of garlic
nice hot pan tablespoon of olive oil
onions and garlic into the pan
nice seasoning salt and pepper
now the secret of a good barbecue sauce
is that really important caramelization
to begin with a nice tablespoon of brown
sugar
it darkens the onions but it really
starts to sort of give that nice syrupy
body to the sauce
and put a little bit of heat in there
now a nice teaspoon of smoked paprika
that's the important part of working
with spices you've got to cook them out
and almost sort of burn off that rawness
especially with a smoked paprika that's
exactly where i want it to go
onions and garlic beauty caramelized
cider vinegar in
reduce that down
now i've got a fantastic smoky base to
complete the sauce i'm making my life
really easy and adding pre-made
worcester sauce and tomato ketchup cook
that out for two to three minutes
now depending on how thick you like the
barbecue sauce that determines how long
you cook it out for i don't want it to
be too
runny but i don't want it too thick
either
that's the consistency we're looking for
lovely
turn down the gas
charger seasoning
now
take that out
it's the kind of sauce that i like to
have sort of bottled up in the fridge
it's great for sandwiches
but goes brilliantly well with these
sliders
homemade smoky barbecue sauce
give the pan a little wipe
now start the mix for the sliders to
give my mix a really interesting flavor
and texture i'm gonna be using unsmoked
back bacon i
travel
all over the world
and i spend a lot of time in the states
they know how to make a great slider
pork sliders beef sliders chicken
sliders and it's almost like a way of
having a burger
but on a much smaller
miniature level
little teaspoon of olive oil
i want that bacon to get really nice and
crispy
bacon in
this just gives the really nice sort of
chunky delicious mix i want texture
and pork is perfect for slider
[Music]
and choppy shallot
shallots are a lot sweeter than your
normal white onion fine fine fine and
then
[Music]
now that bacon's getting really nice and
crispy i want a bit of heat in there a
little teaspoon
of smoked paprika in there
when you see these sliders in the states
for one portion there's like four or
five of them little mini
one biters incredible
now take your pork
just open up
and give that a really nice seasoning
so important you can't season a slider
after you've cooked it it's impossible
so
season it nicely
bake
now that's nice and crispy
just take a little touch
kitchen roll and just drain that off
there
nice
pat that
nice and dry i want all that nice sort
of crispiness
in there beautiful mix all that
in
take
a nice ball and sort of
roll it
the size of a golf ball
get it nice and round first and then
three fingers
just pat that down
don't flatten them too thin otherwise
they overcook and they go
sort of dry
because sliders are bite-sized burgers
designed to go in small buns you don't
want to make them too big
good
get the pan nice and hot
a tablespoon of olive oil
when a slider is literally that thick
about an inch thick
we're going to take two and a half to
three minutes to each side
in
turn them over
lovely
once you've turned them tilt the pan and
just spoon
all that juice back into them
keep my mouth watering now
very easy to dry the pork out so just
feeling it now your fingers is nice and
firm
it's a little touch of springiness in
the center i'm happy with those
add your cheese now so it gets nicely
melted
i'm using wedgies of smoked cheddar
and it has that nice sort of soury smoky
creaminess to the slider
finally shredded baby gem lettuce
just take those
buns make sure they're sliced
nice and evenly
take your lettuce be quite generous with
the lettuce
just a nice thin slice
of tomato
take your burgers
you see that cheese
you feed melted your bbq sauce
place the top on
and that is my version the slider that
is small dynamic but packed full of
flavor i'll take that over a hamburger
any day
you